just flowing on okay um for the people
who were here last time what did we look
at we had a table we were filling it out
initial good the history of numbers well
yeah odd numbers developed over time
okay now a really important bit that we
got to it was the development of this
the place value system okay
also known as Arabic numerals okay now
these are a really big deal
there are big leap from the tally system
one two three four five and there are
big advance from Roman numerals as well
you know stuff like this okay because it
meant that based on where a number was
placed it had a different value we
remember this we're familiar with this
this is the number system we use right
okay so then the question became well
what is it that the digits we have there
are ten of them they're terminal Y Tim
do you remember Weitzman probably
probably because ten fingers maybe not
but probably okay so we have what's
called a um a base ten counting system
okay this is base 10 okay so that means
you count ten times until you get to xi
1 xi number after zero right and that's
when you have a new place okay so that's
why we have units and we have tens and
then tens of tens and so on so what if
we were to differ this right so we're
now thinking about this is the place
we're now thinking about well what if we
muck around with it
what if we have other bases that's what
I think I love today okay yeah yes
that's right so instead of base ten
right so probably the most important
other base that we interact with on a
daily basis kind of is binary binary now
you can even tell by the name what base
is binary its base two good secondary
question why why base
- why would base to be so important why
do we actually rely on it all the time
yeah good excellent now let's let's push
on this right why is it that the
computers that we use and phones and
everything else why are they based - why
not why don't they use base 10 okay all
right so let's push on this a little bit
right
all the data that's represented right in
the world electronically is either on or
it's off but it can be in only one of
two states
hence base to hand spidery let me push
on it again being annoying little kid
why why is it early in two states why
not on or off and in the middle like one
two three or four why only two any
thoughts
what makes computers work like what's
that what's the power that makes them
work its we have switches or like kind
of thing right that are driven driven by
electricity yes and electricity can be
on or it can be off right and back
before transistors back before
transistors there were valves this is
really really old stuff even before I
was born there were either open or
closed there are only two different
states okay so therefore if you can open
up to two first eights when you're
looking at numbers you can only
represent two different numbers and
they're 0 or 1 okay on or off in fact if
you have a look at your computer right
now the on/off switch bears witnesses
fact that at 0 or 1 because what does an
on/off switch look like I'll tell you
what it looks like it looks like a 0 and
a 1 right on or off okay you're
wondering why that symbol was there it's
because of these two digits right so how
does it work let's have a think about
this okay
so I'll give me a two digit number two
did you know anyone ready let's do 20
and then we'll get this away fun
I'll stick 25 up my sleeve and we'll
come to it later let's do let's do 20 so
this is in base 10 okay also known as
decimal right and you can see the UM you
can see the the prefixes that tell you
what the base is strength so to indicate
because we're gonna have different
numbers here right but this is 20 in
decimal I'm gonna write C that's that
one do you see four decimal okay so what
I want to do is work out well what is
this in binary okay how do you write
this number in binary which is which has
been for sure well to start off let's
just think about how to count in binary
okay because counting in decimal were
very good at work so you start at zero
right and then what's the next number
after that
but then because we're in base2 there
are no more digits there are these here
isn't ones
so my next number is not to I don't have
that symbol right what will the next
number be it'll be one zero right now
you can so that it looks like ten
doesn't it but the name start to get
confusing cuz sign is it this this 10 or
is that tip so I call that one zero okay
now just like here we went 20 right this
is how many units of God and this is how
many tens we've got right this is how
many units you've got and this is it's
not based any more space - so what does
this number signify how many twos you
have okay does that make sense what
would the next number be one one not
quite eleven don't get confused
okay now I'm stuck when I count to the
next one right because I've got no more
digitise I've got attitude so I have to
go and add a new digit right have a look
at this this is how many units this is
how many twos and this is how many now
we usually call a hundred right like so
if I have 257 right that's that's a
hundred that's how many hundreds there
are really it's how many ten Squared's I
have and here are how many 10 to the
ones I have and here are how many ten to
the zeros there are units right so here
I've got units
I've got twos and I should have fours
right that makes sense so this is zero
we would read at zero one two three now
hold on I've missed one haven't I
something before this isn't then this
that's a 4-0 what did you for okay
what's next
yeah okay where are we up to I need
another color easy to lose track this is
all in binary
so in decimal you'd be going 0 1 2 3 5 6
7 ok so far so good
see how do you see why it's 7 by the way
look how many ones do I have how many
twos do I have how many Falls do I have
one plus two plus four seven
okay so now we're standing at the haver
how would I go in the other direction
because I don't really want to count all
the way to 20 like you can see this is
taking a while I'm gonna wake up to 7
right so how do I work out how to write
this right it's all in terms of powers
of two isn't it right so how many ones
twos fours I guess the next one would be
8 then how many 16 and then how many
thirty twos right so in fact what we'll
do is we're gonna write this out like so
work out what to put in here okay so
this is how many ones there are this is
how many views there are how many fours
how many eighths
how many 16 and how many thirty twos and
I could keep going if I had a bigger
number right
how many thirty twos are there in 20
it's up to zero how many six teams are
there there's one okay now as soon as I
write down as sixteen all I've got left
is 4 right that's what I've got left
so how many eighths are left none how
many fours I really established this
there's one of them and you can go
backwards and you can check it right
this is going to be 4 plus 16 which sure
enough is 20 so this is one zero one
zero zero in binary does that make sense
okay now that's bass - and that's pretty
simple that's kind of cool now yeah I
could read computer language okay let's
push on this a little further
okay most people know that computers
right they don't just have individual
numbers right by the way each one of
these is called a binary digit just like
you know normal digits in numbers like
this right but binary digits a bit of
mouthful so they also call these is
anyone know what they're called they
contract it and they call them bits
right so Briggs is just the contraction
of binary digits right each one of these
is a bit they don't know come in just
single packets they actually tend to
come in packets of the know how many in
packets of eight eight bits like this
one four five six seven eight okay right
can I count yes I can count eight bits 0
no hey this is called a byte that's
right okay so what's the biggest number
you can represent with a byte think
about this well the biggest that would
be you put ones everywhere right now
what is this number
what is this actual number think about
it
how would you work it out you might know
what it is on your head how would you
how would you do this this there's a
there's an obvious way which you say
well you add 1 2 4 8 16 32 64 100 yeah
right that's one way you could do it
don't know what you'd get good with that
before right you would get 255 ah but
there is an easier way much easier way
right have a look at the numbers I've
already got here can you see this have a
look for instance at this one here see
that it's all ones right all ones I got
seven
look at this one it's also all ones but
it's two digits and then I got three and
then this one is all ones one right I
can tell you right now even without
without doing the numbers if I had one
two three four I would expect that
number would be fifteen can anyone see
why what's the pattern it's binary
remember powers of two are good if I add
one to each of them this would be 2 4 8
16 256 this is actually this is to the
power and 8 minus 1 so it's 2 to the n
minus 1 for however many bits you've got
so therefore think about this a little
bit if I've got 255 the biggest number
right how many possible numbers can I
represent with 1 but if my biggest
number is 255 how many choices have my
god go to new 56 that's right I've got
all of these ones all the counting
numbers and then I've got 0 if I put
them all those zeros